hello everyone this is brinda this is
scholar department of bioinformatics
pondicherry university i'm going to
present my work on
uh microbiome four different lung
diseases a cooperative sixteen years rna
meta genomics to understand the
diversity and functional profile so in
this study we collected four different
lung diseases from ncbi and it's
subjected to taxonomy assignment
followed by functional analysis so
firstly uh it was aimed to compare the
microbiome of all the lung disease
sample with a healthy sample and to show
the effect of cigarette smoking in male
and female patients by evolving the
abundance and diversity across the
sample second is that finding the
possible biomarker to treat or monitor
the dc severity and co-infections
finally profiling the functional
properties associated with the disease
lung microbiome then
in this study we collected as i told
before four different lung diseases we
were having some set of criteria to
collect the sample so first is the
sample with lung diseases
so it is it should be collected from
respiratory tract and sample with gender
and smoking history and the source would
be 16s meta genomic and padding so with
this criteria we collected uh pneumonia
associated hiv lung cancer soprano
disease and sibo pd then
after collecting the sample we we went
for preprocessing uh by using the galaxy
fastqc and trimometic tool and also we
use silver energy as the inbuilt silver
incremental aligner then after free
processing that uh filter sequencer was
subjected to d replication the d
replicated sequences were mapped against
the silver database with a similarity of
93 percent then that samples were
classified and clustered together and
assigned to otu table then that oto
table was consolidated from all the
microbiome then normalized using tss
normalization method that normalized
table was subjected to diversity
statistical and functional analysis so
in the preprocessing section
we can see the number of samples
with respect to male and female and
smoking history then finally uh that
control sample also here uh except
pneumonia reminding all the micro uh
microbiome are having the control so the
pulled control sample from these three
were the control for pneumonia then here
we can see the sequence quality also all
the samples were having the fret score
of more than 20 so here i have given
that example quality check plot then uh
this plot is called refraction plot it
will tell you that sequencing depth and
also oto abundance
then in result section uh we started
with this is like microwave diversity
and abundance for diversity measurement
uh we used a pass for the standalone
tool it is having the set of parameter
to measure the diversity of the lung
microbiome so among these or four
microbiome which one is the most uh
diversified that is the aim of this
particular
task so we found like lung cancer is the
most diversified hormone based on this
ecological parameter then
uh the relative abundance of different
lung thesis microbiome from phyla to
family as listed here so here at final
level we found like uh fermi cubes
adreno bacteria bacteria and then
finally proteobacteria are the uh top
most uh abundant phyla we found in this
study and uh after checking the
literature we found like these are the
common uh pyla which will present in the
microbiome of human then for a genus
level
we use the
venn diagram representation from this uh
plot we can tell like what are the
common and as well as the what are the
unique genus for uh
each lung microbiome so we found like
211 uh genus were common to all the lung
diseases in including sk pathogen so
specifically for sk pathogen to compare
against the control we use star bar plot
in that we found like uh these sky
pathogens were common to all the lung
diseases and these are abundantly uh
seen in
almost all that microbiome then uh to
check the probiotic level um
compared to control sample the
probiotics uh bifidi bacteria
lactobacillus were uh comparatively less
in uh control uh comparatively less in
this lung microbial compared to lung
control samples then uh we went for a
network analysis also using pass
correlation compositional data network
analysis we found like hemophilus the
respiratory pathogen which is a common
hub in all the
lung diseases uh in with the smoking
history and in non-smoker we found like
aloe verbatila the moderate pathogen
found in all the lung disease sample and
then uh along with that hemophilus or
hemophilus we found sk pathogens such as
acinotobacter
enterococcus and
klebsiella are also the hub in all the
lung diseases with the smoking history
then with respect to gender
we found except copd remaining all
through three lung diseases um
we're having a significant difference
among uh smoker and non-smoker but in
copd we found like non-smokers were the
most uh
significant difference um
then we went for functional analysis for
functional in function and analysis we
used megan
that standalone do
in this analysis we found like membrane
transporter is the common and render is
to function in all the uh lung diseases
compared to control sample the two five
to 15 fall higher in all the lung uh
diseases then we went for cat.cat
database analysis in this uh this cat
database is the comprehensive antibiotic
resistant database uh so in this
database we found like uh tetracycline
resistant genes were uh high in all the
lung diseases compared to this control
then we went for uh pathway analysis
using cage uh so here we found like beta
rate beta lactam resistant pathway
generated in that all the lung diseases
and the resistance is mainly due to rnd
transporter so rnd transporter of the
transporter which present in the
bacterial membrane so the the mechanism
of rna transporter is that reflecting
the antimicrobial agent from inside the
cell to outside the cell uh so blocking
this or targeting this membrane
transporter from all the sk pathogens
found in this study it's one of the way
to reduce the dc severity and
co-infection of the lung diseases uh so
and along with that uh supplementation
with probiotic also one of the way to
reduce the severity and for infections
so these are the references i uh gone
through in this study
thank you